it's gonna be fun when we see jt
brubacher on the mound he's been one of
the better young pitchers in baseball
this season very impressive in his four
starts opponents hitting under 200 an
era just over two
tommy edmonds going to lead things off
swing and a miss at a fastball from j.t
brubaker he strikes out edmond to start
the game here's rookie dylan carlson
lifted in the air out to deep right
backing up polanco at the wall
it's off the top of the wall
so one out double for dylan carlson 21
feet high
and he just missed a home run here's
paul goldschmidt bouncing ball past the
mound shortstop comes over and newman
throws on to first nice little play as
he clicks it sidearm toward colin moran
and dylan carlson now at third with two
down for nolan arnotto the wind is
swirling there arenado lifts a fly ball
into shallow left it may drop and it
does scoring will be dylan carlson
arenado with a double and it's
one-nothing cardinals on a two-out rbi
head paul de young cardinal shortstop
foul tip for the strikeout a couple of
k's but a run-in to the bottom half of
the first inning pirates
will face john gant who
is back in a starting role now for the
cardinals he's a one and two in four
starts at 225 era this season here's
adam frazier the lead off man and hits
it right to paul goldsmith one pitch one
out here's eric gonzalez the former
cleveland indian there's arenado
and there's two away then there's brian
reynolds the pitch and that is hit hard
to the second baseman from the outfield
grass tommy edmond throws out brian
reynolds one two three three ground ball
outs for john gam tyler o'neal will be
the first batter against jt brubacher
the one-two pitch
there's a called third strike three k's
for brubacher line drive hit into center
by andrew kisner and the cardinals now
have a runner at first one out and the
return of harrison bader swung on and
missed brubacher has punched out four to
a stolen base and an air has polanco a
third with two outs without a chance to
even the score with the base hit here
3-2 pitch by john gann
hit to the right side and there's tommy
edmond
so no damage done face it for tommy
edmond good start for the cardinals here
in the top of the third dylan carlson
scored the game's only run swing and a
miss and a big punch out for brubacher
one out he's getting a lot of k's
that's five strikeouts there's paul
goldschmidt swinging a miss and again
brubaker gets a cardinal to chase that
slider strikeout number six
nolan arenado and he bats with tommy
edmond aboard three and oh the count
arenado is swinging on three and oh and
it hits it a mile high into shallow left
newman can't get there neither can tom
and racing all the way in the hustle
play
how about that of tommy edmond never
took it for granted it drops in orinato
gets a base hit and it's two nothing
cardinals
ball has to be caught and it wasn't did
off walk to a guy's one for 16. that is
not the start john gantt wanted to the
bottom of the third here's the pitcher
brubacher let's see if he squares gets
the bunt down can't
we'll flip it over to tommy edmond and
they've got him picked off unbelievable
where is he going he's had a miss
playing left and now a miss play on the
bases
holy smokes tom's not having a good
debut today out there in left field or
on the basis cardinal left fielder tyler
o'neill leads off the top of the fourth
inning two nothing cardinals high in the
air to left center field that's deep and
that's long and that is way gone oh my
was that a big fly over the bullpen in
deep left center field a huge clout by
tyler o'neal he has struck for the fifth
time this year and it's three-nothing
cardinal back-to-back walks
to start the bottom of the fourth inning
four walks for john gant
in three plus innings here is jacob
stallings here's a 3-2 pitch to
stallings
and he struck him out he gets caught
looking for out number one here's
gregory polanco and polanco lines it out
to left but o'neil is there to make the
catch
so the inning is turned in the cardinals
way after back-to-back walks to start
the inning and that brings in kevin
newman line drive left field and a base
hit brian reynolds will score bucks are
on the board that's a big hit it's three
to one walk does hurt john gant they
usually do runners at first and second
with two outs and
tom will bat from the left side swinging
a miss he struck him out and that is
strikeout number two for gant both in
the fourth inning fifth walk surrendered
by john gann
and it's first and second here's eric
gonzalez there's a ball hit right in
front of the plate a tag for an out
throw to third out great play by kissner
to get a double play to get defo trying
to advance to third on a ball that was
hit right out in front of the plate it's
frazier at second with two outs and
brian reynolds to the plate a swing and
a fly ball that's hit into short center
field and belongs to harrison bader he
makes the catch so gant gets around a
single and a walk to open the fifth
how'd he do it he goes five innings and
he's eligible for a win
and the runners hold on at first and
second two outs and it's going to be
matt carpenter pinch hitting with two on
carpenter one for four with a home run
against this right-hander and gets
another pitch to drive out to deep right
center he's done it again
how about that back-to-back days off the
bench three-run bob carpenter
six to one cardinals so the base is
loaded todd frazier so pinch hit and now
a buck has been called wow that's a way
to get a run home a ball called on the
new pitcher whitley so it's a 6-2 ball
game here's the 1-0 in the dirt skips
away and another run will score on a
wild pitch
and another run in and now it's 6-3 a
four-pitch walk to todd frazier puts
runners
at first and third for adam frazier the
swing and there's a lane shot one hop to
de young he picks it throws it and gets
adam frazier but the sixth is finally
over and that's out number two and it
brings in colin moran he's a hard hit
ball and that's played by arenado on the
short hop and he throws out moran my
goodness so many balls hit hard today
and at the wrong people and nolan
aronado would be one of them he is so
good with the glove he comes up with
another gem he throws out moran and a
one two three inning for cabrera well
how about a two out rbi here for paul
goldsmith who has struck out three times
tonight hit back up the middle
and an air
air committed by frazier that allows a
run to score and the cardinals now the
lead is seven to three the pirates are
down to their last out eric gonzalez is
coming up with frazier on first base a
ground ball to the left side of the
infield de young has it the shortstop
throws out gonzales for a red bird
winner with the ground out to short this
ball game has come to an end